stranger things is a show about kids
that could even be mistaken for a kid
show but grown-ups watching the series
will notice a lot of details that might
escape a younger eye
this is what only adults notice in
stranger things
at first glance hopper's just a likable
classic tough guy caricature
he drinks every night not just a beer or
two but drinking to the point where he's
numb drunk
in season one of stranger things his
office knows every morning means quote
coffee and contemplation
hopper rips cigarettes all day and when
he's not downing a delightful combo of
eggo waffles whipped cream and candy
he's regularly devouring plates full of
fried meats
as a kid it seems funny how he eats like
a slob but as an adult you wouldn't be
wrong to think the man is an alcoholic
just a few terrorist
fistfights away from a heart attack
hopper spends basically every day
in season 1 hungover he doesn't get
drunk as much in season two although he
has
a nightly beer or three or six he's the
kind of man who's likely never eaten a
salad
nor could one imagine him on a treadmill
though he does have
a pretty physical job filled with stress
and the occasional protracted fight with
a russian terminator
while in the 80s it was still pretty
acceptable to survive off nothing but
greasy meat
that wasn't a healthy way to live throw
in hopper's heavy drinking and you have
a man who today would be considered on
the edge of physical collapse
mike and nancy wheeler are two of the
most dynamic
interesting young people in hawkins
which makes it astounding that their
father
is as much of a detached non-presence as
possible
he's completely oblivious to the fact
that both his children are wrapped up in
a multi-dimensional battle against a
super monster
so is mrs wheeler but eventually she
seems to realize that something is up
with her kids
by season 3 we learn that there's more
to her than meets the eye and if
anything she's simply been dragged down
by her narcoleptic husband
mr wheeler despite all the drama
revolving around them
never notices anything out of the
ordinary aside from a speech about
teamwork he gives to mike he spends
most of the time at home sleeping even
more mr
wheeler is a dud of a husband at the end
of season 2 we see mrs wheeler's jaw
drop when billy stops by while her
husband is passed out in his easy chair
by season 3 we realize how unfulfilled
mrs wheeler is in her marriage when she
makes plans to meet billy at a motel
even though she doesn't act on them mr
wheeler is an inattentive father and
husband but in reality it's tragic that
he's surrounded by people so full of
life while he
densely snores away yes these kids
are nerds choosing to hang out in the
hawkins av club instead of the football
field with basically no friends outside
their group
except their science teacher in fact
they may be the whole of the hawkins av
club
for their public school to have a ham
radio and an av club is certainly out of
the ordinary
but nerds are not they have some pretty
expensive hardware
their radios the radio shack trc 206
trc 214 and trc trc219
weren't cheap plus dustin has a headset
and later builds
cerebro a portable super powerful radio
at science camp
the boys certainly have free reign to
play with expensive toys
while their parents were likely more
than happy to encourage their scientific
endeavors the walkies and hundreds of
batteries they must go through in a year
would make a pretty expensive outlay
and this is before everything had usb
charging cables
murray bauman is the consummate
matchmaker in stranger things
when jonathan byers and nancy wheeler
come to him in season 2 for help the two
teenagers have
a bit too much vodka and wind up
sleeping over
bauman is surprised they're not together
and says they should just have sex
they protest and jonathan volunteers to
sleep on the pull out
that night the teenagers can't sleep and
when neither can hold out any longer
they take their friendship to the next
level
the next morning at breakfast bauman
asks with a wry smile
that was the pull out a kid watching
will think he's just joking about the
fact that jonathan didn't sleep on the
pull-out sofa bed
a grown-up however we'll see the double
entendre he makes with the pull-out sofa
and
a particular move that happens in the
bedroom
during interrogation the russians give
steve and robin a truth serum
the drug could be anything but based on
the reaction
at least in a grown-up's eye it's likely
a psychoactive drug
it's worth mentioning that mk ultra the
program that gave rise to 11's psychic
powers
was known in the real world to
experiment with hallucinogenics and
psychology primarily for interrogation
purposes
when steve and robin start laughing and
joking with each other
to kids they seem drunk but adults will
understand that they're tripping
they seem drunk why would they be drunk
after having a mind-blowing experience
watching back to the future on
hallucinogens steve lists it as one of
his favorite movies when he interviews
to work at a video rental store while
sitting outside the theater the lights
on the ceiling of the mall begin to send
off chasers for robin and steve
that lands them in the bathroom throwing
up and then having one of the greatest
heart to hearts in stranger things
history
considering that these two were dosed
with some strong psychoactive drugs
steve's quick recovery and ability to
drive a car are pretty astounding
there is no way to explain how it was
having only one phone in the house
younger people will never understand the
necessity of taking a phone call
standing in the kitchen
in front of anyone who wants to listen
because the phone was mounted on the
wall next to the kitchen
for the grown-ups who mostly remember it
the central shared phone brings back
conflicted memories yes there was
something nice about not always being
accessible
but it hindered mobility and privacy
sometimes that short cord was replaced
by a long one you could stretch into any
room in the house though it was easy to
figure out when it was a private call
and even if you were in another room you
could never guarantee the call was
private
like when mrs wheeler picks up the other
phone to listen in on mike's call with
l only to hear him lie about his
grandmother being ill
as an adult in the era of play dates
constant chauffeuring
and stranger danger it can be shocking
to recall a time when parents let their
kids go off on their own all day
yet the kids of stranger things bike
around by themselves from house to house
over what is likely miles of empty road
in season three of stranger things
lucas's 10 year old sister
erica is left completely unsupervised at
the mall
her parents don't even seem to notice
that she spends basically a day in a
russian bunker
in the 80s kids were mostly left to
their own devices they made friends on
their own
biked home by themselves and their
parents let them take care of themselves
most of the day
sure that lack of supervision allowed
will to be snatched by the demogorgon
leaving his brother in charge of
surveillance duty but it also empowered
the kids to figure out what was going on
and save him and eventually the town
without parental intrusion
the old world was very disconnected
compared to our present world which adds
a lot to the story in stranger things
only grown-ups will fully notice and
remember how disconnected it was
after all how many times is everybody
separated and looking for each other in
this show
if they had cell phones they could
easily call each other to figure out
where everyone
else is located yes the kids do that
with their walkies but as we see in
season 2 they're not always equipped
with these handy devices
in the modern connected world however
people are constantly cell phone
accessible
today many parents have gps trackers on
their kids cell phones
but in this series there is no easy way
to figure out where the children are
in season one we see how much time
hopper and company spend
researching to find out that hnl was
involved with
mkultra in season 3 when the group
doesn't know planck's constant
they have to get dustin to use his super
powerful radio to connect to his
brainiac girlfriend
susie in salt lake city because she is
the only person they know who
understands the mathematical formulation
with the internet however you can look
up plank's constant in half a second
planck's constant is 6.62607004
in season 3 of stranger things we see
the impact the star court mall has had
on the small town of hawkins indiana
before malls people walked through
downtown areas going to random shops and
in bigger cities department stores
but shopping was mostly about
independent shop owners and locally
owned stores
or sometimes mail order then malls
brought in chains owned by far-off
conglomerates and while everybody
protested the death of downtown
districts
the malls became a central point of
american culture
they started in big cities but quickly
spread to smaller towns
many adults have memories of the early
days when they would go to the mall and
spend a few
hours walking around shopping catching a
movie and eating at the food court
this type of shopping center dominated
for a few decades until the internet
came around
now malls are lamenting their demise at
the hands of e-retail
ironically buying local in-store or
online at downtown shops seems to have
made a great resurgence
kids today may never understand how for
a brief while
malls were king in season two of
stranger things
steve and nancy go to the home of barb's
parents to talk about her disappearance
the parents couldn't get it together to
cook so they ordered kfc for dinner
joe kiri who plays steve harrington
spouts ad worthy lines about the finger
licking good chicken and adults who grew
up with overt product placements would
likely take notice
brands and storylines were a constant
since tv evolved into a machine driven
solely by ad revenue they were
eventually replaced by more expensive
commercials followed by the service
subscription model
and another product placement an adult
might notice new coke
lucas sounds like a commercial as he
pontificates to his friends on the
quality of this soda
in 1985 new coke was an attempt to
revitalize the brand and lucas's
description sounds like perfect
advertising
coca-cola even reissued new coke as a
tie-in to the show
in that regard stranger things has used
an old marketing trick in a
tongue-in-cheek way to bring old-world
marketing to modern television without
pricey commercials
california may have lost some of its
luster given the growth of other cities
and the high cost of living but in the
80s it was the place to be
while chicago enjoyed popularity thanks
to john hughes and new york has always
had a strong presence many movies and tv
shows about adolescents in the 80s were
set in california
in many ways the trends found in
california trickled to the rest of the
country
as evidenced by lucas and dustin using
popular phrases around max
you're super smart and you're like
totally
tubular this was the era before social
media and online shopping
when the only way to know the trends was
to be in the epicenter
so to leave that world would almost be
like falling back in time
small towns could be a season a year or
more behind the trends
billy is infuriated by this though his
status as a guy from california gives
him
instant cachet in hawkins with that said
leaving california for some place else
would have hit harder in 1984 than
almost any other time in history
because of this a person can almost
understand billy's frustration
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite streaming shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one